we have a lot of special guests here
today in our committee oh let's see
do you have a name tag a name can you
pick Ah that's not right though do we
all right thank you okay so uh welcome
to ways and means everyone welcome back
for those who are used to being here and
welcome to all the people who are
substituting today we have a school
vacation week we have some other
absences so uh we'll do the best we can
but welcome and thank you for joining us
today uh do you want to introduce
for terms in criminal justice three
terms in transportation one this current
term is federal relations
thank you for joining us just just
another uh reason for me not to have put
in for Ways and Means oh not because I
don't like the people I don't understand
what's going on
and representative fellows is a regular
member
representative DeSimone
thank you good morning Madam chair uh
Deborah DeSimone I represent Rockingham
Atkinson I serve on
children and family law this is my
seventh term there and I did serve one
term on Municipal and county for my this
is my eighth term
um
I my other life I'm involved in finance
so that's why I would never ask for this
committee you are the tax collector for
your town yes so you do have some cred a
little bit a little bit and I thank you
all for
um accepting me thank you for being here
and representative Darby welcome thanks
uh so I'm uh will Darby I'm from Nashua
this is my first term I've I'm on the
resources committee I'm really excited
to see what happens in other committees
so that's why I was uh eager to
volunteer for this um I'm a software
engineer software manager in the rest of
my life
welcome and representative Southworth as
a regular member good morning
representative Ames very experienced
regular member representative all me
representative janigan representative
Sanborn representative Platt were all
regular members representative Malloy
and oh we have a new face representative
Ellison oh yes all right Allison I
represent Merrimack 28 which is uh
Concord Wards one two and three
and I'm on education so for those of us
on education starting at 10 o'clock in
the morning seems like a vacation
well welcome very happy to have you here
and representative spilsbury a regular
member representative Doucette regular
member and representative Tanner welcome
uh thank you very much
um I'm Linda Tanner I'm from Sullivan
five which represents Sunapee in
Springfield I've served four terms on
education one term on labor and just
couldn't get enough I guess through
education so I'm back here today I'm a
retired teacher thank you thank you so
much for being here representative soti
a regular member Roberto Smith hopefully
he's joining us representative alberger
to today okay well we'll do the best we
can
so that's okay we'll we'll do okay today
and just you know folks we're doing the
best we can we have limited data we've
spent a lot of time and effort as you
know trying to get our head around these
numbers uh but the best numbers
that we could get are in March and April
and we don't have those so we're going
to do the best we can with what we have
and we'll at least come up with
something today that we can at least
move forward but we can always come back
and revisit these numbers as we continue
to watch the trends so we have about
five or six remaining categories that we
haven't taken straw votes on yet we will
do those this morning
once we get to a nice place that we can
all agree we will then take a lunch
break and crochet in the legislative
budget office will put those numbers
into a spreadsheet that we can look back
together at and really make sure it's
accurate
and assume it will be and then we will
take our full final vote on that but
we'll be doing straw votes throughout
and having discussions throughout so
this is a little bit different from a
regular Bill hearing where we're not
hearing from anyone from the outside
anymore we do have a very expert person
with us the commissioner of the dra who
can help us with the numbers because
today we are dealing with some of the
bigger numbers and and her office is the
one that knows the most about those okay
awesome so we have uh like I said
several different categories I thought
it might be nice if we start with
something relatively simple
uh which would maybe be the utility
property tax
uh which if you look at your worksheet
is column o
chair Sanborn yes do you want to just
explain the worksheet to the new members
so they understand what they have
absolutely do they all have does anyone
have a copy of this worksheet now
okay so uh this worksheet uh has
different columns with different
categories of revenues and you'll see
there's a letter at the top and so we're
going to page six column o which is the
utility property tax
and we are working on
straw votes basically for three
different numbers what we expect
revenues to be for the remainder and the
total of fiscal year 2023 which ends
June 30th fiscal year 2024 and fiscal
year 2025.
and generally women we've been making
motions for the straw votes we do it all
at once but we list those three numbers
on the spreadsheet you'll see what the
original plan was you'll see what the
governor's estimate was and then you'll
see the range of possibilities that was
given us from the experts which are the
agencies that manage these things and I
think today almost everything is from
the dra so and we have the pro here
Okay so
I would recognize representative Platt
thank you madam chair I'm going to
propose numbers for the utility property
tax and the thinking behind my numbers
is that the agency has done a great job
coming up with its estimates and I'm
essentially splitting the difference
between their high and low and I heard
comments the other day about record
profits well the utility in the utility
property tax is partly based on Netbook
and partly on Revenue estimates but uh
the the revenues uh I I just happen to
be I came from science technology energy
my background was utilities I look at
ISO to go today we look at their prices
they're they're three three and a half
cents which is down to where they were
before uh things went crazy a year and a
half ago so yeah the profits are not
there anymore and I don't expect once we
go into this uh I don't expect much
difficulty with
the with the generators
uh there that I don't see record profits
go continuing and the utilities the
polls and wires utilities they charge uh
for fixed costs with a kilowatt hour
basis uh rates per kilowatt hour so if
they have a lot of sales their profits
do go up but then they go down when they
don't have the sales and I just don't
see anything sustaining those sales so
I'm coming up with uh for the three
years
42.8 which is splitting the agency uh
for 24 43.5
and for
fy25 44.1
just so you guys can see what we're
looking at on this spreadsheet
um when it says hwm estimate on line 13
19 and 25 that's house Ways and Means so
that's the number we're trying to plug
in right now
so everyone got those
great do I have a second for that
43.5
so that would be the midpoint between
the agency's low estimate and the
agency's high estimate is that what
you're saying yes okay is there a second
representative fellow seconds
now we'll open it to questions comments
and thank you for that
um
the uh
FY 23
I'm wondering whether that's affected At
All by what uh what income profits uh
utilities may be making now given that
it's pretty much baked in what their
um
their property tax is going to be
my answer is the agency would have taken
that into account in their estimates and
they and so I'm splitting the difference
representative Army
thank you
um could we ask the commissioner
why there's such a range when I thought
good morning Madam chair members the
committee welcome to new members today
Lindsey stepp commissioner New Hampshire
Department of Revenue Administration
um the reason for their ranges is that
there even though the values are set on
December 15th for the prior April 1st
those
the estimates that we receive after that
date are really for the tax year for the
next April 1st where those final values
will not get determined until next
December so typically utilities true up
between their estimates and their actual
so utilities may make additional or may
modify the payments that we're going to
receive between now and the end of
fiscal 23 in anticipation of what their
value for this coming April 1st is going
to be so that's how you kind of end up
with a range
so even though the value is known
they're also making estimates
essentially for the next year so that's
the reason for the range and some
I think you had mentioned too in your
presentation that they could appeal in
this so there's a little wiggle room
there in case they appeal so that's a
great Point utilities can appeal the
valuations they had until February 15th
to do so we did have appeals come in so
there is some unknown about the amount
of Revenue that we will receive for the
remainder of the year because of that
representative so forth uh thank you and
partly about procedures too my numbers
were about a million more than the
previous Representatives but I'm also
wondering uh to what extent a million
dollars difference we're going to be
well that's why we're discussing this if
the million dollars is really important
to you we'll listen to your logic but I
think yeah a million dollars may not be
worth a lot of discussion so you know I
think depending I would concur if that's
how other people felt but I I was a
little higher than his for what I do
okay
plus we can do it later
true I'd rather if we can get to a
consensus on each individual item we're
building up kind of building it up from
the bottom up versus like a top-down
number right so if we if we agree on the
bot this number and the other blocks
we'll get to a number that I think we
can all agree on
uh it's you already second the motion so
is there any more discussion
representative orrs
thank you madam chair and uh welcome
especially those from the educational
side of things God bless you
thank you for taking my question so in
your numbers I I know we talked about
this a little bit before but you've
baked in everything you can possibly
think of is that correct inflation
what you know a meteor falling from the
sky whatever
maybe not the meteor
um but yes we have tried to analyze you
know everything that's kind of happening
um again as I've mentioned previously
maybe not by making specific adjustments
to the revenue estimates but using
inflation profits of utilities
valuations that we've seen new types of
utilities potentially coming online that
has informed us on which scenarios to
present to you as part of our range so
yes
representative Army
I'd like to hear representative
southworth's uh reasons for adding a
million I think we're talking just about
the first one because the other ones
flow
from it yes that's exactly right I think
um I felt that um it more optimistic
about 2023 and then the other two flow
and why are you more optimistic may I
yeah um because I do think um the
returns will be I mean I understand her
explanation that they might not be
steady but
um I think
the changes will happen more in the
future and that won't necessarily
there'll be changed right now in the
last few months of the 2023.
so just to clarify representative
Southworth you're talking about
potentially editing his motion for FY
2023 to 43
um no I think we have to vote on his
motion I was just giving my input and I
think my input just is that I felt that
by the time we finished 2023 it will be
stronger let's say a little closer to
the governors for the figures on here a
little closer to their high end than the
42 Point um
one that he put for
that okay but it's not something that's
a hugely important to me if I'm just
all the comments yes representative Ames
the question to the commissioner um the
governor's estimates are higher and um
is that
I can't remember the budget director was
here but
has there been an adjustment from the
governor's office do they agree with a
lower number
I won't I don't know for sure if they
necessarily agree with the lower number
I think the difference between the
numbers is the timing of the estimates
so the governor
um was presented with a range of
estimates at the end of December we came
to you with estimates at the end of
January January is a month where we
receive utility property tax revenue so
it's just an example of updated numbers
based on more Revenue coming in
I'm looking back at my notes that I took
when the governor's person came in and
his revised estimate was 40 it was
originally 47.1 and then he said now he
said it was 46.3 just so you know that's
what I had in my notes
so it was it's uh
still higher than what we're talking
about but not as high yes representative
Phyllis I'm thank you madam chair I'm
looking
to document the version that we got
earlier the version we got on
maybe February 7th
and on page 50 it gives you like 10
years of the actual
revenue from this tax so it's really it
the the green line across here is just
above 40 and you can even see from where
you are that it you know it kind of goes
either side of
representative horse
thank you madam chair so when I'm
looking at your numbers
you exceed the governor's estimate in
2025.
it's correct so on the high end or we
come close to oh I'm sorry
uh our high in 2025 is above the the
governor so the reason for that is you
will see the governor's estimate is flat
in all three years 47.1 our range is the
result of a small amount of growth in
the tax so that's how we end up slightly
Higher by 2025 so we start out lower but
we assume the high estimate assumes a
small amount of growth and so we end up
a little bit higher by 2025. okay thank
you and uh can I make a short statement
sure so having done this kind of work
myself I think I hopefully can just
help the committee with any angst they
might have in the Numbers number one
number uh number two
being that I was a registered
independent for years until I got tired
of waiting in line and I ended up in the
party that I am now
I'd love her numbers that's all I wanted
all right so we have a motion
unless there's more discussion
all those in favor accepting
representative palette's motion please
okay it looks unanimous that is
wonderful and so uh how many people do
we have here can you count that
oh
I I think it's 18 but somewhere else
Madam chair I used to teach math maybe I
could help representative we might need
that
the education committee is here because
okay so let's take a look at Insurance
what column would that be guys
f
okay column F on page four at least on
my copy
which is the insurance tax
also very tight numbers between the
my my uh suggestion is we don't bucket
uh that the governor and the agency are
right on the uh Copa static essentially
so I go with the agency numbers of 139
139 and 142. is that your motion that is
my motion is there a second to that
representative fellows seconds the
motion
okay now we're open to discussion
representative only
I don't think that we have sufficient
analysis by them or by and obviously we
can't do it
um but
in with the lack of that I go along with
what they've got
just FYI for everyone here we would hope
to have another Insurance presentation
yesterday but we got snowed out we did
get an email with more data
um certainly once we get through some of
our deadlines of other bills that we
need to hear and so forth if we want to
have them come in and work with us we
can certainly do that
should we take insurance out on our rest
of it
I um I'm content to go forward but I do
want to put this caveat in
um we don't have insurance here and we
all know why and that's fine but they
did send us something and that was
helpful and I want to point out amongst
the other uncertainties is the Medicaid
expansion program which uh Mr Betancourt
spoke to on the second page of his
his submission Under The Heading Health
Care Market a major issue first it is
important to remember that the revenue
collected from the mcos for the Medicaid
expansion program is segregate
segregated to pay a portion of the
state's 10 non-federal share second as
you're aware are aware the state is
going to begin the process of
redetermining the Medicaid eligibility
for 101 000 people of that HHS is
projecting that 59 000 individuals will
be ineligible
and finally it is unclear where those
individuals will get coverage we know
that some portion of them will migrate
to the individual Market but we don't
know how many or the impact on premiums
and I highlight that just because it
there is a level of uncertainty in this
one and in some of the others we've
already dealt with and that are coming
up and I really think it's important
that we reconvene on the revenue issue
um
you know after two or three weeks
um when we'll have more information for
sure on the uh the major dra
revenues and maybe as well we'll begin
to have effects on what's happening with
Medicaid expansion
I concur exactly on that because we we
we're hamstrung a little bit right now
with data but we hopefully I'm thinking
about a month from now we'll be in a
better place to have some answers there
representative Almy
yeah
I'd just like to point out that
whatever change happens in the insurance
Market because of a very bad decision
made about I don't know 12 or more years
ago
um they're
by the Senate naturally there was on
there is a doubling of that change from
year to year so it's very unlikely we
end up with the same numbers year after
year
and if there's a big change it will be
twice as big that year and
okay all those in favor accepting the
motion to accept the
the agency estimate which is across the
board
it looks like it's unanimous anyway in
opposed
great so if our numbers are right that
would be 18.
excellent thank you
okay uh right next to that is e interest
you're gonna be bold again okay you're
representative but again the agents has
put a lot of thought into this and I
don't see anything I mean yes we're
going to face a recession uh but but I
don't see how that affects necessarily
interest and dividends tax of
significantly and so I would go with the
midpoint of the
agency
which was one-third is 135 in
uh 2023
112.8 in 2024
and 89.4
in
2025 and the 89.4 matches the governor
the
1.128 matches the governor the 135 is
the it also matches it so it's a
Governor's estimates all through in this
case
which is lot the low side of midpoint I
think of the agency
representative Southwest Essence thank
you
okay let's talk through it
this one is one of the most volatile
and the governors and and the agency see
it going down
we should we
just lost that's built into the law
but let's go five four three two and
they're
and they're taking it down the next two
times does that include
the um
the reduction in rates yes yeah oh there
on so what is the equivalent of that in
terms of
of where we are now if we had the same
because if we do have a recession it
so the estimates the governor's
estimates
assume I and D will be flat
23 24 and 25 and the reason for the
reduction is the change in the rate the
we
estimate that the impact in fiscal 24
will be 22.2 million and the impact in
fiscal 25 will be
from the tax law change so it's really
just a flat number and then applying the
tax law change is how you get the
representative Spielberg
thank you
I think further looking at dra's
methodology they are projecting uh low
to high being based on a zero percent
and a two percent growth
so something that splits the difference
or comes close to that at the governor's
level is essentially estimating one
representative
I
I am not sure that I have the document
with me about on where the growth has
gone but I do know that last year's was
the strongest
grew 22 percent last year over the prior
year
that was fiscal 22 grew 22 over fiscal
21 fiscal 21 grew 17.8 percent over
fiscal 20
was a decline of 4.6 percent over fiscal
19 and fiscal 19 was a 7.4 percent over
fiscal 18.
so yes we have seen significant growth
in the last two years with interest in
dividends tax
Madame Jared
yeah I'm sorry I can't see you over
there apologize representative
Southworth he likes to really focus on
um just to confirm this tax again is
again kind of like the upside down
triangle yes probably not to the same
extent as the business taxes but yes it
has that similar effect of the triangle
where the point of the triangle or the
majority of the revenue is from a few
number of taxpayers so you're really
talking about how stable their
Investments are over the next two years
correct and if you remember from the
presentation the majority of at this
point the majority of the interest in
dividends taxes coming from
distributions and so to the extent that
distributions and dividends decline due
to a slowing in the economy that would
slow your growth in IND so I think
that's how we kind of arrive at that
zero to two percent
increases that we anticipate the economy
slowing we understand that the majority
of the IND revenue is driven by
distributions and dividends and so when
that economy slows the growth in those
areas will slow as well causing the tax
to slow
thank you so again Madam chair I was
leaning higher but I think
um when you mix those factors in I'm
more comfortable with one percent or one
percent
of Ames and then I think representative
Platt did you have your Independence my
question just got answered okay okay
good
Samson
my question to you commissioner is um
is uh when we will know with greater
certainty the FY 23 numbers and is it
true that at the end of April
you will have a pretty good fix of how
these where these going to come out
whether they'll be low or high or
midpoint
that's correct so April is the most
telling month for the interest in
dividends tax because it is the month
where we receive return and extension
payments for the prior calendar year and
also the month that we receive third
quarter estimate payments for the
current year so we get prior year
information and current year information
at the end of April the only the only
thing that's outstanding before the
close of the fiscal year is June
estimated payments so but June estimated
payments would be the last quarter
payment so we generally have a decent
idea of what those payments are going to
look like because we have three quarters
of estimates preceding it so yes long
answer or short answer yes it'll be the
end of April we'll have a much better
idea thank
representative ORS thank you madam chair
and thank you for taking my question so
is it the numbers that were going up
substantially I think was 21 22. is that
money possibly driven by the influx of
cash that came out of Washington number
one and number two
my stock portfolio is like it's dropped
like a rock and so I'm just wondering my
stock advisor doesn't even want to meet
with me he suggested counseling
and so I'm I'm seeing the trend going
you came up but I'm seeing it heading
down substantially for a little while
your your guess
so going back to kind of what I said
earlier I think we feel like the growth
that we've seen the
17.8 percent the 22 percent growth
largely driven by influx of money and
profits in the economy
um but that that growth is going to
representative Ames
isn't there a caveat to that again
another one of these things that
um interest
coming in maybe maybe significantly
higher
correct
I just want to get for you the breakdown
again of Interest dividends in
distributions
interest
for tax year
[Music]
represented nine percent of the total
interest and dividends tax that we
receive so I think even with an increase
in the interest due to interest rates
Rising the decrease that we're going to
see in the remaining 91 percent of the
representative Army
thank you do you have how much uh the
revenue dipped in the.com I wouldn't
want to compare it with a Great
Recession I don't think it's going to go
that far
do you want to give me specific years in
the.com that you want to look at well
house oh
[Music]
on
1999 no 2002. okay so yeah ing Revenue
from 2000 to 2001 grew 17.9 percent from
2001 to 2002 it dropped seven percent
from 2002 to 2003 it dropped 21.1
percent
2003 to 2004 dropped 4.7 percent and
then 2004 to 2005 we saw growth of 24.5
percent
2005 to 2006 20 growth and then 2006 to
so that was a mild but
but
targeted towards the strengths of New
Hampshire uh recession on or the
weaknesses in that particular case
but I want to remind people also when
we're looking at what happens in April
it was last year
It's a combination of returns for last
year and estimated payments and we can
break that out for you and give you that
breakdown between return and extension
payments which to representative almie's
point would be last calendar year versus
those that are estimated payments for
the third quarter of this year
representative fellows did you have a
question
um can you just explain to me the
difference between
distributions and dividends I know what
Dividends are but what how what are
distributions so we provided to you via
email that like what we call the IND
checklist
um and that kind of lays out for you all
of the things that fall within the
interest in dividends tax but
distributions would be a distribution
that you receive from a corporation as
opposed to a dividend so similar idea
um they're just categorized slightly
differently in how they're laid out on
the form so that's how why we break them
out but there's a really long list of
everything that falls under the interest
in dividends taxes that we provided to
the committee
so do they generally go up and down at
the same
rate
I don't have the breakdown of the data
for the time period that I just read you
the changes in the tax but let me just
look
quickly
in what we provided to see if I can
gleam anything
they do seem to generally track
consistently
representative spilsbury I apologize you
know just so you know guys because it's
a little hard to see if if you know you
want to ask a question or speak if you
turn on your mic I'll see the red I'll
I was just thinking maybe I could help
representative fellows with an
illustration of not a Hardline
definition of the difference between
dividends and distributions but
dividends tend to be something that is
issued
on a more or less regular basis for
example quarterly
a certain percentage and what have you
of profits distributions tend to be
something that's more of a unusual
situation one-time event
for example if there's say a sale of a
division of a corporation
or subsidiary
and that sale may be partially a stock
sale partially a cash sale the cash then
may be distributed
to the shareholders so it is based on
your percentage ownership shares but
it's it's because of a one-time event
another example would be smaller closely
held corporations where you have a few
owners and they're essentially dividing
out the profits at the end of a year in
order that's the way they get their cash
as opposed to say for example the
foreign
on the table
everyone knows what that is right
every everyone opposed raise your hand
okay want to post right okay the two I
apologize okay
what let's keep going and uh let's go
that we've all got the same numbers
could somebody so I believe uh under
column e interest and dividends
the numbers that were put forth for 2023
were 135
and for 2020
but that was 2024 I hope I said that
right
okay
gotcha
uh all right so we also we have what
three more to go these are the tougher
ones obviously with a lot more moving
Parts
um
let's let's take a stab at business
taxes that's the big one
I know but we got to do it
we're gonna rip the Band-Aid off
representative spilsbury
thank you madam chair
um
I would like to make a motion I'll
say what my free numbers are and then
after we have a second speak to them
so for
FY 23
uh one two three five
we're FY 24
uh one one nine eight one billion 198
million
and for fy25
uh one one seven four one billion one
okay I need a second and then we'll open
second okay representative Platt seconds
okay now
let's talk about it representative orrs
Madam chair can I make a counter motion
or let's say not yet let's talk through
this but it'll be apparent in our
discussion what your thoughts are okay
oh my thoughts were we just round these
numbers up
it's the accountant to me yeah
I thought you'd want to balance to the
penny uh representative Platt Madam
chair I'm I'll accept these numbers but
I'm even more pessimistic than those
numbers represent we're facing a
recession a timing is uh not sure
certain but the feds are going to keep
racking up interest rates and that's
going to put a big damper on the economy
it's happening already and I I read all
sorts of stories in the Wall Street
Journal factual stories that lead me to
concern uh people running up credit card
debt like crazy uh the the Walmart and
Home Depot saying people are getting the
cheapest things they can they're
downside down to being Thrifty and all
sorts of stories like that so I'd be
even much more pessimistic but uh so
anyway I'll support the numbers
reluctantly because to me they're too
high
you want to tell us how you got to that
there's a lot of debate and no certainty
about whether we will or will not have a
recession whether the FED will magically
uh have a soft Landing or not
but the one thing that's clear
is that the FED is on a mission and
they're being very explicit about it and
their goal to tame inflation is going to
require
that they push interest rates up even
further than where they are so far uh
most typical estimates I'm seeing are
that will end up around 5.5 percent
which could be another three raises or
four this year maybe another percent
more importantly whatever they end up at
they're going to have to hold them there
for a good year to the optimistic
scenario that they're going to somehow
hit this magic little balance and
immediately start tapering
is highly unlikely
so when you look for analogies in the
past it's hard to find one this is
certainly very different from 2008 nine
perhaps it's a bit more analogous to
what was going on in the late 70s
and as a result of that their concerns
being expressed by experts that we may
enter stagflation If the Fed is not
aggressive enough and not successful
but what's really different is that
recessions usually occur
because of market dynamics
and the federal government following the
theories of Keynesian economics
will typically then step in
to try and counter the rest recession
with fiscal stimulus
this is not going to happen this time
because what's different is that this
rest this recession
is manufactured by the government to
address a bigger problem which is the
risk of persistent inflation
so I think when we see head fakes from
the market optimism uh and and your
watch stocks as a barometer there's
almost an inverse relation that you can
anticipate the more those stocks start
to Surge up based on optimism
the more the FED Governors will sit down
at their next meeting and say huh our
message hasn't gotten through we need to
be even more aggressive so the recession
to one degree or another is going to
come and when it comes the typical
reaction of fiscal stimulus won't be
there
so I am predicting that for 23
the midpoint is
1.238 and I settled on a round figure
just below that so just a little bit
more pessimistic than the midpoint for
the balance of this year based on what I
see in the January and February numbers
and by the way just two caveats we don't
need to explain because we've all talked
about it that includes a distinct uptick
in refunds
in the last couple of months and it
includes our knowledge that we have a
large amount of tax carry forwards in
our state treasury
that companies may claim in a time when
their cash is tighter in a recession
so therefore my presumption for 2024
is that we decline three percent from
from that level from the million from
the 1 billion 235
down to 1198 is a three percent drop
and that we have then declined two
percent further in 25 so that's my
rationale
thank you very much other comments
representative almie
thank you we did get a
on explanation of the major refunds we
saw in the last two months which was
that it was related to the distribute to
the companies that which are usually
very big companies that get an extension
until October
uh
and
I agree with you on a lot of this
on but added to that we do not know what
the tax structural tax changes we made
you mentioned the credit carry forward
there's also what the single sales
factor is going to
show to us next year not this year but
next year
um
and
and we have been chipping away at
at the rates of the tax which always
have a lag of one to two years in when
they tell us that it's made a difference
so we have
it's
it's just pretty impossible I think too
look at this
but
I would go with with your numbers
more on
I'm afraid but I just point out that
they will be rounded if you look down
the numbers that
that's totally acceptable to me strange
numbers on them are ones that that were
put in the kafir which I refuse to call
an act for
aquifer
somebody says agva yeah aquifer yeah
representative
well I guess I'm The Optimist you turned
your mic off by mistake oh yeah I was
just turning off the signal but now I'm
back on
um
so I guess I'm The Optimist
um if you want to call me that or maybe
I'm the skeptic who's sat here for 10
years as we've made predictions at this
time of year
that often are wrong
of recessions or of uh of good times and
um so I I I guess another word would be
humility I approach this task with a a
lot of humility and uh not too much
confidence in what economists have to
say nor do I take any anything from what
the stock market's doing one month to
the next
um so
um so I
I
um and also I I had the experience time
in year in and year out of seeing Ways
and Means numbers uh
um replaced by Senate numbers which uh
are always higher and that's because
they've got better numbers they say well
we had numbers but we chose to be
cautious and uh so I'm I'm sort of at
the point where I'm throwing caution to
the wind and wanting to apply to these
numbers the information that I've gotten
uh that was all of us have received that
uh for example that the dra believes
that the low and the high are both
credible numbers
and they've thought hard about inflation
and recession possibilities and
timing of payments by different kinds of
businesses and so forth and so on so I I
take a lot from that
and certainly would not go as low as as
this motion would take us in fiscal year
25 I wouldn't get close to that
um so uh I'm going to be voting against
representative I would ask
representative Schomburg what his number
would be
same same sorry
yeah well
um
is that in order
yeah we're having a discussion so yeah I
mean I think what I just heard is you're
particularly concerned with the 2025
number did you have some other thoughts
on how to get to that number five number
I would I would uh
thank you other discussion
representative orrs
and oh I'm sorry representative
Southworth is your thing on yeah okay
we'll come back to you after
representative orders probably have to
like hold this up I yes I apologize
we'll do ORS and then it's all you
um thank you madam chair so yes I was
noticing uh 2025 the agency estimate is
higher and it gave me pause that maybe
representative Ames
is correct in that maybe that number
instead of one one seven four might be
one point
two or one point nine
uh I'm sorry one nine uh as I mentioned
earlier uh I'm looking at what looks
like around the number so I have a
question for the commissioner
being that the agency number is well
above the governor's number more than a
rounding error
do we have an explanation as to how the
agency got there I'm sure you have one
thank you for your question
um our high estimate
assumes that our percent over plan is
maintained through the end of the year
was subtracting the tax law changes
the low assumes
that we kind of remain
um
what we've seen here to date and then we
are at plan for the rest of the year so
that's kind of the two different
scenarios
that you see
you're asking about fiscal 23 correct
five five the height the high okay
so
the high in
25 is the result of remaining 33 ahead
of plan for the rest of 23.
two percent growth from 23 to 24 and
another two percent growth from 24 to
25.
the governor's estimate assumes no
growth
and the year to the year changes are
just the result of changes in the tax
law so we essentially our high is two
years of two percent growth as opposed
to the governor assuming no
year-over-year growth that we don't go
into a recession we don't decline year
over year until you take the tax law
changes into effect but instead we just
kind of stay flat for two years okay
thank you follow-up question please
follow up
so I know you may not be answer able to
answer what I'm thinking but based on
what I heard from representative Ames
Terry that was a joke uh so it sounds to
me like
we're good I mean I'm good with the
numbers being presented here with the
exception of 2025 based on the fact that
the governor shows no growth
and I think in 2025 we should show a
bump in the agency estimate maybe above
again 1.17 and it should be maybe 1.19
or
uh even even a tad more could be 1.2 but
the other numbers look good I mean if
you had to just hold your thumb up and
to win or however you do it would you
concur with any of that or just tell me
to go home
if I held my thumb up in the wind you
would get the numbers the agency is high
representative Southworth thank you for
taking my question so again I'm
picturing the upside down triangle and
they're what 16 or so
multinationals that basically control a
so
and
I know I'm simplifying but it's I think
no you're 20 or less that are the really
big so right so for tax year 2020 there
were
um
78 that paid more than a million dollars
in tax
um
I can't tell you who they are right
um but what I think we talked a little
bit about
on Monday was
fairly consistent
that there's a small number of taxpayers
that are kind of in that point of the
triangle but the taxpayers in that point
even though I can't tell you who they
are I can tell you that they can change
from time to time yes depending on those
Industries or areas of the economy that
are performing strongly in that tax year
that we're looking at
yeah
um so
you know we mentioned you might have
seen during covid you know medical
devices and retailers maybe come into
that point of the triangle if we go into
an economic slowdown maybe the retailers
kind of fall out of that trying that
point in the Triangle but maybe
um you know others come in for different
reasons
uh thank you so I'm similar I believe to
representative Ames I was feeling we
could take the midpoint of their low and
high
I think the big questions that really
don't have answers yet are would it be a
recession I certainly would go along
with the idea of a Slowdown and also
what is the timing as far as how it will
hit the years I think that's it's
something we can't answer but that's
basically what we want to know to get
these figures more accurate
it's your midpoint remind me is that one
percent per year
or when it's not quite when I did that
would be yes because our range was zero
to two yeah before the tax law changes
so yes into your the point that you're
kind of just making in terms of timing
I'm sure people saw in the news this
week
um survey of some economists when they
were surveyed back in November December
time frame felt like we would see an
economic slowdown or maybe a recession
happening within you know the first
quarter the first half of 2023 they were
surveyed again last week and they've now
bumped that feeling out a couple months
right so I think the feeling is that
there is going to be a Slowdown
I think people thought it was coming now
they're not as confident that it's
coming as soon as it's going to so it to
your point it is a timing question yes
um and that point kind of keeps moving
and question for the chair
um would we vote on the motion on the
floor first
and then we could have because you
mentioned some different numbers as well
then there can be other motions after
that or do we want to slow down and work
on the percentages first and then have
I mean we have emotion right now we do
have a motion and
um I'd like to hear a little bit more
about what we're you know where we're
maybe disagreeing uh and what
percentages people would use
um and just to hear a little bit more
about that and then maybe we'll see if
the person who made the motion would
like to amend his motion let me try it
that way representative fellows thank
you madam chair
um my first thought is that I don't
connect
the revenue that's going to come in with
business profits tax to anybody's
Investment Portfolio I mean the price of
stocks go up and down you know Walmart
you know I don't know what their stock
does but they're going to have strong
sales no matter what
so
um I think
I just I'm not willing to go as low as
the proposal for I mean for 20 for 23
I'm fine you know with the number
proposed but
I think I think 24 is a little low I'm
more inclined to take the agencies in
high and low and split them and also do
the same thing for 25. but I just I
think I think people
you know they think about how it fits in
how how a recession will hit individuals
but that doesn't necessarily change
income and profits for large
corporations which are the ones that are
you know primarily are focused that's
just my thought
okay other Representatives over here
represent Ames your light is on did you
want to say something now all right
there are two people over there one of
them representative Elber
I tend to agree with representative Ames
and representative fellows that the
numbers in 2024 and 2025 are lower than
I would be going with and if we wanted
to split the difference between the
agency's low and high for those two
years
we'd be looking at
1.224 in 24 and 1.235
in 25 and I would be looking at
something kind of in that neighborhood
okay great yes representative
Spielberg now you've got me screwed up
spillsbury
thank you madam chair
um
representative fellas I agree with your
observation that uh what's going on in
an individual portfolio or in the stock
market generally isn't an indicator of
What kinds of taxes
are larger businesses are likely to pass
but at the same time it's also not the
case that their gross revenues are
necessarily an indicator of how much
taxes they're going to pay
what's likely to happen in a recession
is their margins are going to get
squeezed their revenues May grow without
pulling their profits up
so I continue to maintain my concern my
very fuzzy crystal ball is just slightly
less murky in 24 than it is in 25. I
feel fairly strongly in my conviction
that we're going to see a downturn
sometime in 24 which
covers a large band of uncertainty in
terms of timing
from third fourth quarters of 23 to
first and second Quarters at 24.
so I would not go along with the
midpoint concept especially not for 24.
now once we set a figure one two three
five for 23 and we back it down for
three percent at that point
going to the midpoint of the agency's
estimates for 25 simply is nonsensical
because it's predicated on completely
different base points for those
percentage adjustments however
if it would help generate a consensus I
think the committee's done an
extraordinarily good job in this process
of of coming together
I I would welcome as a friendly
Amendment the 1190 figure that
representative Orr suggested for 25
and with that adjustment I wonder
representative Clinton
well what I've heard others speak they
were more uncomfortable with the 1174 in
25 and so you could make that the same
1190 possibly I don't know
representative
thank you madam chair
um in trying to
take into account the motion and
listening to everybody's thoughts
um
I have I do agree with representative
spilsbury in in the sense that the FED
has stated that they will keep raising
rates until they make sure that
inflation comes down
inflation while it's come down a little
bit is still stubbornly higher than the
FED would like it they want to bring it
down to two percent
that's still a long far away from where
we are right now at somewhere around six
to seven percent so the FED is going to
continue raising those rates that's
going to affect
all sorts of things from Real Estate
um
purchasing to purchasing
automobile whatever interest rates are
affected and it's also going to affect
the retail sector so I think while
it's reasonable to
or or knowing that the FED is going to
continue doing this
and we don't have a model where we can
look back to a recession where this
matches
nicely I think that in 2020 you know I
think we're pretty much in agreement
with 2023 that's good
um 2024
um you know I think the number
representative spilsbury put out was
1198.
maybe we round that to one two zero zero
and then the bigger question becomes
2025 and um
what I'm hearing is
there's some thought that some feel like
it's going to go down a little more some
feel it could be flat
I think going to the agency's uh
midpoint on 2025 might be
might be a little over optimistic
knowing that you know still remembering
that the FED is going to continue to
make sure that inflation is low and to
do that they could severely have to pull
the economic
nature back so
um I so I I would
possibly throw out the fact that maybe
we leave 2025 flat instead of the two
percent decrease then you've got
12 35 for 2023 as representative
spilsbury said we just round 2024 up to
one two zero zero
still believing that it's you know we're
down close to three percent and then
2025 flat at 1.2 so I'll kind of throw
that out there to see how people feel
about that
representative ORS thank you madam chair
so uh I want to agree with
representative fellow spillsberry
uh janigan and uh Al Berger
thank you and that where I think we're
all in agreement on 2023 uh as I said
right off the beginning before we had
all this discussion I believe 2024
should be bumped up a little bit and
trying to move things along I think uh
rep Janine made a great point about
possibly taking that to 1.2 which is a
little higher than I initially spoke of
but again
we're talking rounding errors and none
of these numbers really concern me with
the exception of 2025 and that I think
it's a good idea possibly to stay with
the 1.2 as a representative dinnigan
just said and even if we tweak that a
little bit we're talking really
immaterial dollars here so I would
encourage us to come to the consensus
now and let's move it forward thank you
I think I agree with that also but I
want to remind people inflation is
additive
we are talking here dollars before
accounting for inflation
so uh
I I think that this is it may actually
end up being
more than what we're talking about but
with worse
results
because of the inflation
thank you I just wanted to check with
the representative spilsbury so if we go
with
um 1235 for 2023 you're thinking the
revenue will drop 35 million for 2024.
Justin thank you okay just to make sure
I have the right yes
and uh I think we're in a zone now
um where we've pretty much said what
needs to be said and we could go for a
vote and if if it's the sense of the
committee to set 25 at 1.2 even and show
it flat for 24.25 I'm perfectly content
with that
I have a few more hands up
representative orrs thank you madam
chair so uh
going right to 2025 I think that we're
all good with 2023 and 2024 though I
could be wrong and in 2025 I think rep
Almy made a great point about the
inflation I recently read where
Britain's inflation rate is 17 I believe
our inflation rate based on things I've
talked about in previous committee
meetings and as I mentioned instead of
seeing my stock broker I'm seeing a
psychiatrist
that we we look at that number and maybe
it is a little higher in 1.2 maybe it's
1.23
1.24 or five but whatever the number is
I agree that there could be a little
more bump there in 2020 three and four I
don't see it it looks like uh the
numbers are down thank you
representative I wonder if it would make
sense to separate out and just vote on
2023 because I believe there's consensus
on that get that done and then just
I see heads nodding so um do you want to
first amend your motion to just 2023 for
now and then we can try 2024 separately
glad to take it in three parts okay
great one billion 235 million as our
forecast for fy23 okay do I have a
second on that
lburger
excellent okay all those in favor of
accepting the 2023 business tax number
all those opposed
okay unanimous excellent thank you
great idea okay so then that brings us
to FY 2024
and would you like to make a motion
again for that
yes I'll move that for fy24 we pick the
nice round number of 1.2 billion
okay is there a second for that 200
that's a two million Roundup
second for that representative all me
second set thank you
all right uh
all those in favor of accepting that
all those opposed raise your hand
yep yep so one two oh oh
all right and then let's take a look at
2025 representative spillsburg yes so
the third motion for fy25 would be uh to
hold it flat again at 1.2 million even
1.2 billion yeah is there a second for
that
oh representative soti seconds that
okay all those in favor of that number
okay I'm not going to do some counting
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten eleven so there's 11 and how
one two three four five six seven right
okay well we have you know a majority
that supports that but I'd rather us get
closer to something we can agree on uh
representative all me
yes I've been thinking since
there is going to still be inflation
going on but we're also going to be
dealing with more than 10 percent of
inflation total in the last few years
probably more like 15 on
that it should be
should be up at least
um I don't think
the commissioner considered inflation
it would be my same answer previously
there's not a specific adjustment for
inflation but the impact of inflation we
would say is accounted for in the zero
to two percent growth rate
so if there's an economic downturn but
inflation
helps to buoy that in some to some
extent then that would be in the growth
rate
so uh follow up I would I would go
considering this because I think the
inflation is a lot more than we've dealt
with for quite a while on to
which is about the midpoint I think just
looking at it
one two five so as a terms of a
percentage increase from FY 2024 what
would that be three
percent that's three percent yeah the
actual the midpoint of the agency
estimate is 1.235
let's just you know keep in mind we
think about percentages you know the the
dra in their good judgment thinks a zero
to two percent growth from 2024 to 2025
is reasonable so just keep that in mind
Representatives
uh thank you just for clarification
um at least for me even if I don't agree
with all the figures that's not to say
when we get to the final number that I
won't you know put it all together and
support the committee
but I just reserved you know my opinion
on some of the individual lines but that
doesn't mean I'm not going to support
the whole thing at the end
excellent thank you for clarifying that
uh other comments Representatives Ms
Pillsbury
thank you madam chair
um
inflation obviously is at play
it may inflate prices of goods sold and
revenues received but I would remind you
that inflation will have two counter
effects
one is it will also raise the cost of
goods sold
and the expenses of the corporation and
will tend to squeeze the margin because
they are running out of room to adjust
their prices up further
um and uh
and second I think that companies that
run into tight cash times if not
outright stress
will be looking for ways to mitigate
taxes and to take refunds against their
representative lburger did you wanna
yeah
this is one of my I'm new and I'm
ignorant questions
how if at all do we tax online purchases
yeah we have no sales tax on products
liquor gets taxed if you buy it online
yeah so you know but if you're buying
things from New Hampshire companies
theoretically their profits would go up
their payroll would go up so they're
paying more taxes on all their activity
foreign
representative Phyllis so
that's an Amazon pay business profits
tax
yes they would so yeah the business pays
and as we move to single sales Factor
the percent or the portion of their
profits the portion of their profit Pi
if you will that gets allocated to New
Hampshire is based on the sales that are
made into New Hampshire so while the
consumer doesn't pay when they purchase
something from Amazon they don't pay a
sales tax that sale contributes to
um the the ratio that we'll use or the
fraction that will be used to determine
Amazon's profit pie that would be
representative only
uh I'm not sure how to factor this one
in but on WE according to the combined
business chart that you gave us which I
find very interesting we have 78
BPT pla payers above a million dollars
but only 16
b-e-t
which means that most of those are
well to have a bet liability you would
have to have payroll in the state right
so they have some amount of of presence
here in the state but the you know the
business Enterprise tax is a smaller
rate on a different base than the BPT
and so when you get to that high dollar
amount that greater than a million
dollar figure
um
bet doesn't bet just doesn't generate as
much revenue as BPT
so there's fewer people in this category
representative Doucet
just point a clarification we've already
voted on 25 correct
no we we did vote on 2025 and the the
vote count was 11 to 7 and so we do have
a majority but I I thought it would be
helpful to continue discussing I would
much prefer a stronger majority so that
we can all walk out of this room feeling
United
um so that's why we're continuing the
discussion if if you'd like to
um I it would be nice if we could get
somewhere where
all sides could be more comfortable
representative fellows
so I would just like to add one of the
things that I'm I don't know but I have
some kind of sense of in my mind are the
business sectors that we have in New
Hampshire
for example we have a lot that are
related to military
you know things that the military buys
from us and
um you know be the biggest employers
like Bae and
some of those that that those are not
going to be negative in negatively
impacted and I don't think that
purchases on Amazon are going to be
negatively impacted because one of the
things we know is that a
relatively High portion of our
population
has enough income that they're not
really feeling a pinch
so that's kind of the pieces you know
which you know I'm trying to put
together a puzzle and I only have a few
pieces but those are a few of the pieces
that I'm considering uh representative
did you have your hand up I'm sorry okay
go ahead thank you madam chair
um to representative fellows I I guess
you're you're correct in the sense that
people are going to keep buying things
but there's already it's already been
documented that people are
kind of so we say downsizing their
expectations so if they typically would
have bought you know
um some some good that's valued at
twenty dollars they're now trying to
find something that's a little cheaper
and maybe it's 17
and the one of the things that that I've
read recently is that even people making
a hundred thousand plus are are like Max
many of them are maxed out something
like 70 65 or 70 percent of them are
maxed out and so they also because of
inflation are trying to you know
downsize in terms of you know they still
need to buy whatever it is but they're
buying the cheaper version of it and so
as a whole that's going to bring total
gross revenue for even a big company
like Walmart down a little bit so I
think you you probably still would there
is going to be an effect
representative Almy and then we'll go
over there on I think the commissioner
can answer this question uh the I
believe the military
it's hard to answer that question
specifically without because there's
well there are oodles of military
procurement people in this state I will
just say to representative fellows point
I think I mentioned this in previous
discussions as well
one thing that New Hampshire has going
for it is we have a diverse base of
businesses that pay our business profits
tax and our business Enterprise tax
that's one of the reasons why we did see
a decline during covid but we didn't see
the significant impact that some other
states may have you know you can think
of states that are just solely or not
solely but a large portion of their
revenue comes from tourism
or you can think of states that a large
portion of their revenue comes from oil
and gas and so when you have
fluctuations in those sorts of
Industries their profit their profits
are impacted and then the state revenues
on their business profits tax are more
severely impacted we have a more diverse
base of businesses that pay our tax so
when there are winners and losers in
terms of Industries and the impacts that
the economy is having on those
Industries our tax can stay a little bit
more stagnant and is a little bit more
resilient
representative
thank you madam chair so
um
given that most people
agreed on the 2024 I think it was the
vote was 15 to three and
given that dra was looking at a zero to
two percent growth
um
if we take the the average of that and
say it's one percent growth we apply the
one percent to the 1.2 that most of us
agreed on in 2024 we end up with a
number of
1.212 we could raise that slightly to
1.215 so if if we said 2025 is 1.215
um
well I guess I'll make them I'll make
1.3
no no we went down to 1.2 basically so
I'm basing it on what most of us agreed
on for 2024 which is 1.2 one percent
yields a 1.212 what I'm saying we can
make a little bit higher 1.215
so I'll make a motion to to change uh
is there a second for that
anybody want to second that
representative orrs
okay so we have a new proposal for FY
2025 maybe we can get more consensus
there
uh representative Darby I apologize I
missed you earlier
thank you um Madam chair the only two
things I was going to mention
um was first you know I'm just speaking
um from my own experience my company
recently had our uh you know our
earnings report for uh 22. and one thing
that caught my attention was that
um because of the increase in interest
rates they're actually making a much
much larger profits on their uh existing
cash the cash on hand because of the
interest rates than they had in the past
but more more importantly there's two
very large
um uh what's the word bill is coming out
of
um that have already been passed out of
Washington the bipartisan infrastructure
Act and the inflation reduction act that
have only started to
um to make their that the money's only
started to flow into the states and so I
I personally believe that that's going
to have an offset to the um to the
Slowdown that we're seeing um you know
this year
thank you thank you uh representative
Army did you
uh no that's
okay okay so we have a motion it's been
seconded other comments on that motion
yes representative Ames
um just to pick up on that last point
which I hadn't been mentioned it's an
important Point there's significant
Federal money
um that already is flowing into the uh
our economy here in New Hampshire uh
from the previous Federal actions that
hasn't been spent yet a huge amount of
money there and now we've got these the
infrastructure act and I can't remember
either either one of these names but uh
in any event uh a significant impact
there so it's one more reason why I
I listened to the to the sort of
negatives and to the positives and uh
almost throw my hands up I wish I could
but I can't and so I uh I come out on
the upside I'd be I'd be content to go
with the
proposed uh 1.215 as a con in the
interest of compromise
and that would be for both
uh as I understand it both 24 and 25. no
the motion because we had already agreed
fairly heavily 15-3 on the 1.2 for 2024
so it'd be
just for 2025 would go to the 1.215 so
you got give me that again okay so what
we all agreed on unanimously on 2023 was
the 1235 and then on 2024 1.2
and then 2025 The Proposal in front of
other comments representative Platt
Madam chair in the interest of Comedy
not comedy committee uh I would go along
with the 1.215 but I think we're being
overly optimistic I think the economy is
going to take a severe recession
representative ORS thank you madam chair
so yes in the interest of time and
everything I would go along with 2.124
or whatever it is
yes and I agree with rep fellows that
you're going to see stronger Walmart
sales when the economy declines but it
doesn't mean Walmart's going to do
better uh number one number two having
worked as an auditor with the Department
of Defense and on the other side of the
fence as both a consultant and an
insultant I can assure you that the
economy will affect the defense industry
it's not going to be Rosy I've been
through layoffs of 1500 people it's
never pretty and so also I I believe
that this is more of a rounding error
than anything so I would go along with
two point whatever it is just to be done
with it
thank you
well keep in mind with business taxes
we're talking about billion so this is
not rounding this is where we're getting
you know tens 30 million dollars kind of
range so that's why it becomes more
important for us to go through this to
see if we can get a comfort level
knowing that our crystal ball is very
cloudy right now yeah so having having
worked with billion dollar contracts I
guess in my just from my experience to
me it's like it's not a big deal but
lucky you
okay so we have a motion on the floor
um for FY 2025 business taxes for a
1.215 all those in favor please raise
your hand
okay one two three
four five six seven eight nine ten
eleven twelve thirteen so I'm gonna
okay all those opposed raise your hand
one two three four five so five okay we
are much closer
I'm not sure we're closer because I
think some of the ones who voted against
it voted for it in the opposite
do we try this again or did I get the
okay let's try this one more time so now
we're just voting on FY 2025
for
1.215 all those in favor please raise
your hand
well because someone said I double
counted so Mr clerk please count how
six seven
eight nine ten eleven twelve thirteen
okay all those opposed please raise your
hand
I count three
five five three
four five sorry okay so we had the
number right 13 to 5. thank you very
much mixed between parties yes it is
mixed between parties because obviously
we're trying to find a nice Common
Ground here
right and uh we'll get there I think
that's a pretty decent majority though
we've we've moved in the right direction
um
representative spillsburg thank you
madam chair I also noted that the no
votes were people who had expressed
opinions on either side and I'm willing
to accept that as a fair median and even
though I voted no I'm entirely
comfortable with the result
thank you appreciate that okay
representative so forth
thank you yeah I think it's been a
really good
discussion
drive from Dover and I stayed on the
road
I think you know the bottom line is what
I said earlier recession versus slowdown
and I think it's just a perception that
people have but um I actually have to
say I think we came very close so um I I
don't have an issue with being one of
the no votes
great thank you represent Almy did you
want to say something okay okay well
let's move on and attack meals and rooms
representative Platt Madam chair I
propose
for fiscal year 23 306 which is the
governor's estimate it's within the
range of the dra estimates
uh 297.6 which is again for 24. again
the governor's estimate and split it is
the low end of the agency range and
297.6 for 25 which is also the
Governor's estimate is in the low end of
the agency range and my concern with
meals and rooms
is there a second
is there a second on that
oh representative D Simone thank you
okay go ahead yes my concern with meals
and rooms is we might see a little
uptick as as vendors raise their prices
and it's a percentage of that but I
think people are hitting the wall
quickly and I I gave a little vignette
story again it's not for pun But
Domino's thinks their revenues are flat
and they think they're flat because
people are cooking at home more and
you're in that industry I don't know how
your sales are doing compared to
previous years perhaps you could have
him some insight but I think it's gonna
it's you know when people were not
visiting in covid years they're not
going to visit again for money reasons
as often at least
other discussion representative Army
sorry year-to-date on rooms and meals
has done uh 4.5 percent above last year
it doesn't end
um
this month
it went oh
it was
21.6 above
last year
but that is probably because there
wasn't much snow until recently
and people went out more
but
um
I do think that
it's going to when people buy in the
supermarket they're running into major
and
and it's become
something that most people do a lot of
is either eating out or picking up and
taking it home
and if I go to the supermarket
one of the things I buy is a hot chicken
and that has rooms and Mills tax on it
because it's hot
but it's also juicy at that point and I
carve it all up and and make it into
but
yes I know lunch is getting close we've
got to try to finish rooms and meals and
then we're gonna try to attack real
estate transfer tax and hopefully we can
do that no you know and be done with it
by 12 30 so that we can take a break and
then Chris our lbao assistant can can
for sure the numbers that we're talking
about that are on the table what's
what's the what's the proposal The
Proposal is uh for 2023 306 for 2024
297.6 for 2025
297.6 and basically those are the
governor's estimates and are within the
range of the dra estimates
representative Southworth
ah thank you I went with the midpoint of
the agency estimates again it's just my
life experience I think there has been
really a permanent change in habits of
people going out and it does seem to
affect
um all different kinds of businesses the
fast food lots of takeout the full
service
um and um
I don't think that's going to change
short-term
I do think it'll be uneven within the
state which I've asked about before
I do think the North Country may have
trouble with rooms depending on what's
happening with the economy but the areas
where I spend most of my time which
Upper Valley Seacoast the Concord area
things are booming and I just don't see
a major slowdown in those particular
areas thank you
representative elberger thank you a
quick question I you told us already and
I have forgotten and I you can find it
faster than I can what is the percentage
of the uh meals and rooms tax meals
compared to rooms
so I can tell you for last month
for Revenue that was collected in
February which would have been January
sales
rooms are 18.7 percent food is 76.8
percent so and is is that maybe not
those exact numbers but is that spread
relatively consistent that say 80 might
be meals and 20 might be rooms when you
say spread consistent you mean across
the state across time across time uh
I'll say yeah actually yes the answer is
yes for fiscal years 2018 to 2022 on
average m r was 17
rooms 80 meals so yes what we saw last
month is generally consistent with the
trend we've seen thank you all right so
let me just make a couple of comments
um
my husband and I hope to take our first
vacation in four years this summer
my guess is that many folks have been
putting off long vacations for the last
few years because of covid because of a
whole bunch of issues but I I see what's
happening is
that
people
eat out more partly because they're
bored to tears with cooking at home
uh I am
um and also because well maybe they
don't have money to go on a vacation but
going out to dinner is something they
can manage when I've gone out regardless
of the kind of restaurant they're
usually pretty full
and
I don't see especially given that
roughly 80 percent of uh m r comes from
the meals part that we need to worry
about underestimating in that area even
with potential slowdown I don't think we
need to go with the low numbers that
we're seeing
well that on I think it was Monday I
asked a question about the meals revenue
and did it come from the full service
restaurants or the you know more like
the fast food and the vast majority of
it I don't remember the percentage comes
from the full service
restaurants and that tells me that
the people who have the money
those are the people who have the higher
incomes that are spending that money and
and also tourists and I don't think that
that's going to take a hit I just don't
and so I'm more comfortable with taking
the revenues
administration's high and low in
splitting them
I I don't I just don't think I don't see
representative Ames did you want to
weigh in okay
represent Alberta did you have more to
say sorry no
uh does someone want to
give us those numbers of what the
midpoint would be between the low and
the high so we can think about that okay
good
316.7 and 325.5
I'm trying to figure out how much growth
that is yes please thank you okay so
representative Almy is going to figure
out what kind of percentage growth that
is and now going back to what the dra
said
uh estimated growth range zero to five
because the dra just tells
representative Almy that answer
because you know what you're high and
low is so what's the midpoint of the the
answer midpoint to midpoint is 1.83 yes
but I'm just saying she can just take
her two percents and tell you the
in theory yes
um I actually
just want to provide a little bit of
clarification on representative plett's
motion which was equal to the governor's
estimate
the reason why you see a decline from 23
to 24 going from the 306 to the
297.6 is not actually an assumption that
m r revenue is going to go down it is an
assumption that m r revenue is flat the
reason for the decline is the municipal
Revenue transfer because the transfer
that occurs in any given year is based
so representative plett's motion is
actually just a flat
it's essentially flat m r gross revenue
for all three years the reason for the
decline is because of that transfer that
transfer is the reason why I can't
specifically answer representative
self-worth's question
because the
basically the the net numbers that
you're going to estimate Chris and I
will work to back into the revenue the
municipal Revenue transfer
so that we can get to the actual Revenue
in order to determine the growth if that
makes sense so clarification go ahead um
so clarification
um then for now we should just calculate
as best we can the midpoint between your
high and low and you'll back the other
in and we'll know the percents later of
course in another way you can either do
it one of two ways you can either
estimate the midpoint
or you can just
um
determine the percent growth that you're
comfortable with and then during lunch
Chris and I can do the math to get you
so do we have what your high and low
percents were that's what I missed yes
we are high and low percent we had a low
of zero and a high of five percent so
the zero just two and a half so two and
a half percent is essentially the
midpoint but it may not look like that
when you actually do the numbers out
once we calculate the transfer
if I might jump in just for a second on
you look at rows 9 through 12. that's
where you have the m r
work so you'll see that row nine was a
gross revenue number
and from that there's a transfer to
meals in the municipal fund and there's
a transfer set for school building a
Debt Service
so you can see for 24 there's a range
depending on what your starting point is
on row nine the transfer is going to be
anywhere between 129 8 to 139 million
and then you see the same type of thing
for 25. so what Lindsay was the
commissioner was just saying to you is
that
because you're providing a net revenue
number we're going to have to try to
back into what the transfer numbers are
unless you come at it from
the row 9 schedule if you if you go with
the gross number give that that number
and then we'll give you what your
Madam chairman can I just ask a
clarifying question yes please so Chris
uh if if I'm understanding you correctly
the
low and high percentage adjustments of
zero and five percent have been applied
in escalating row nine yes from 23 to 24
to 25. and if we were to do quick math
on the figures on row 12.
we would find that that spread is
diminished
because as you go up in Gross you share
there was an almond did you wanna
say something
no okay no at this point I think it's
irrelevant that that is numb his numbers
come out to 1.1 percent 1.2 percent 1.3
percent growth but it makes it's going
to look different exactly it's going to
look different when so we have to keep
that in mind as we go forward what I'm
hearing correct me if I'm wrong is that
we actually for the first time we have a
partisan split we have two different
numbers
one that the Republicans have put forth
one from the Democrats
um on all three of these years
and I'm wondering
um so in 2023 we heard 306 versus 311
could we come up with the middle number
there which would what 3085 something
like that
um and then figure out the split you
know so we just come up with the average
between our two points of view is that
something that we could entertain
representative orrs
uh thank you madam chair So based on
what I heard and what the commissioner
just said and Kristen like you said I've
done this before uh I would recommend or
just suggest to my esteemed colleagues
that we accept the number
in 2023
and which in this case whether it's 295
or 306 I really don't care and then as
far as the others I think a split's
probably a reasonable thought but 2020
2023 is definitely going to be on the
other comments represent only
but I'm I mean we
we've got people
we've got a lot of little restaurants
uh the representative plett you made the
original motion would you be willing to
amend that motion as soon as I have the
numbers I will okay let's pause and
anybody else want to say something okay
we'll pause for just a moment you guys
can look at your numbers
Madam chair
I thought I said yes I wonder again if
it might make sense just I think it'll
be easier to just do it in three
I'm not sure where we are
so I did so we're going to make a
revised motion
um because it seems like we have a
partisan divide on this particular topic
and so we have two different numbers
that we're kind of leaning toward and so
what representative plett is looking at
is kind of trying to come up with a
compromise and he's going to amend his
motion with a new number that reflects
both sides so I thought that we were
going to wait for um
are for Chris and
um no they'll have to do their
adjustment based off of whatever number
we come up with yeah I think that's what
we need to do representative Ami
yes I think it makes more sense to give
two or three different percentages to
them and have them bring them back
because the percentages that we're
looking at here don't work
on with looking at what the growth is or
non-growth is in the industry
but if we tell if we go back to page
three
and
pick say it right
one percent two percent three percent
growth
representative Sanborn if I might if the
committee could give
a number for 23 a gross number and then
what you want to grow it by percentage
in 24 and 25 that's a fairly easy
calculation that we can put together for
you
if you give us a net revenue number it's
going to be a little bit more involved
in trying to get back up to the gross
number than figure that all out
and if I may if you give a net number
for 20
four
it may actually end up being wrong
because the municipal Revenue transfer
is going to be based on the 23 amount so
even if you give us a number we're going
to have to modify it so to Chris's point
it might make sense to decide on a 23
number and then a growth for 24 and 25
we'll do the math and can come back and
you can approve the actual numbers
okay representative plett Madam chair I
withdraw my previous Motion in its
entirety and I will make a new motion
for FY 23 a 308.5
which is a split of the difference
between the 306 that was suggested in
the 311 of midpoint
308.5 that is uh higher than the
governor's estimate so it's clearly
within the rage
is there a second
representative spilsbury okay so now we
have that motion and we've discussed
this one at lengths we'll just focus on
that all those in favor of the 308.5 for
okay let's do a count with me one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
eleven twelve thirteen fourteen I got
14.
and all those opposed
one to
you're switching
okay
well we were dealing with the motion
that was giving us which is on page four
and based on the recommendations of the
lbao and
dra we are first voting on
so
depending on which time we either had a
14 to 4 or 13 to 5 on the 3085 for 2023
okay
right that we got okay so now that we
calculated
not for 2023
that's right we know the municipal
Revenue transfer um total amount for 23
because it was based on 22 revenues so
we're fine with 23 that whatever number
you agree on will work the problem is
when we get to 24
that is going to be based on the amount
for 23 and 25 is going to be amazed
based on the amount for 24. so her
suggestion was to you know kind of draw
a line in the sand on 2023 so then that
math works and then from there if we
want to talk about well what do we do we
think there'll be a percentage increase
in 2024 and if so what their estimated
growth rate was zero to five percent so
where do we want to be on that
representative Southworth
thank you so I know you're going to run
several numbers I'd like to see 2.5 for
thank you as a percentage of growth
increase okay other comments on that
representative spilsbury it's a
corresponding request that we see Zero
representative jinnegan
thank you madam chair I guess
um
my question to those
who who would say it's going to grow you
know
let's say two and a half percent if
we're if on the business taxes side we
said we're down almost three percent
um in the next year and then we are flat
it seems like m r is going to
not not perfectly reflect that but you
know in some respects go with that so I
guess I would be
I I would struggle as to why m r would
grow two and a half percent each year
but by business profits would go down so
I think we we need so my my thought is
that that m r
um would probably at best case be flat
from 2023 to 2024 and then to 2025 then
maybe there's a slight growth
representative Phyllis so I would just
say the answer that question is because
I don't think that business taxes will
be going down that much so
the higher amount for room and meals
keeps me kind of with the same Outlook
that I have
representative follow me
and speaking is one who thought that the
business taxes would go down that much
on
there has only been one year since
2008 when we put or nine when we put in
the um
extra money for the uh
the tourism
public publicity that we have actually
and all the rest of the time it has been
going up
I think it started after it lost ground
it went back to three percent and then
it and it's been five percent most years
so
um
it's kind of hard unless we run into a
major major food
crisis again that is lack of lack of
wheat lack of corn lack of lack of meat
then
I think there's going to be growth we're
talking about consumers rather than
corporations when we're talking about
this
and representatively ones from inside of
New Hampshire representative orrs I'm
sorry
thank you madam chair so my question to
you is in if we were to go back and look
at 2005 6789 before the coven
2015 16 17 18 before the covid
what was the annual increase do you have
I do I'm gonna guess that we get right
around five percent my recollection is
that pre-covered years m r increased on
average about five percent which is how
we got to that high of 5 so
um
fya 17 over 16 was four and a half
percent FY 18 over 17 was 5.4 percent FY
19 over 18 was 5.6 percent then we saw a
decline in FY 20 over 19 of 6.6 percent
because we had the the shutdown in the
economy
okay thank you follow-up question please
so if we were to go back and look at
I'm the one who got the publicity money
and
2007 to 2008 we grew 3.4 percent 2008 to
2009 we declined two percent 2009 to
2010 we grew 9.2 percent
so from ready for this
from
1973 State fiscal year 1973
till
State fiscal year 2022
m r year-over-year change only declined
four times once from 74 to 75
second time from 84 to 85
third time from 2008 to 2009
fourth time from 2019 to 2020.
very good so I think my point is that
she confirms what I'm thinking is that
we're going to take a hit in 2023 and
then 2024 and 5 I think it's going to be
a little Rosier just one man's opinion
representative Darby
thanks um uh a couple of quick points I
2008 was a dramatic um you know it's
called the Great Recession as opposed to
you know 2001 2002 which was
um even a very significant uh uh
recession but not nothing like 2008. so
that seems a little
closer in in likelihood although I think
that's I'd be surprised if we hit that
hard but my real point was that we've
actually seen a growth in population for
the last four years in New Hampshire in
fact the the largest growth in New
England last year
um while it's you know while it's a
fraction of a percentage it it does
contribute to those that are going to be
going out and secondly that inflation
does directly affect the rooms and meals
taxed as well and we just had a long
discussion about
um about inflation how inflation is
going to continue to hit us over the
next three years
did you have something no okay uh
representative Madam chair I just want
to understand where we are we voted on
uh FY 23 are we waiting for calculations
before we tackle 24 and 20. no we are
now what we're trying to come up with is
what we believe the increased percentage
or decrease percentage would be from
2023 we've heard 2.5 uh from one member
as uh his comfort level for both years
and we're discussing that out because
it's hard for us to give an exact number
a percentage is easier for uh lbao to
calculate because net of the transfers
so we're trying to come up with a mo I'd
like to hear a motion that would appease
everyone on a percentage increase from
the 2023 level
representative Doucet has this yeah I
just want to offer some perspective here
I think in hearing some of the testimony
I think we can all acknowledge you know
I was just talking to my colleague to my
right that the kitchen table model that
we've all been used to for a lot of
years was uh sitting around the family
kitchen making dinner I I believe that
many more of us are going out and
getting takeout whether it's eating out
take out for for whatever reason
um and I think that we're going to see
an incremental
although small I'd rather see it very
flat growth because people are
accustomed to that now we're probably
dealing with a different model as far as
the family dinner or the family lunch or
sending kids out the door
um but I think we should be a little
more hawkish than 2.5 percent although I
agree you know my personal opinion would
be to keep it flat but uh I I
acknowledge and if we go with the you
know with the 308.5 that we have if we
stay flat in my opinion that's the best
and that's acknowledging the growth I
think so I don't think anybody's
thinking we're going to go down three
percent I don't think that's the case
but I think we do have a different model
and we have to acknowledge that but
let's be reserved in that
okay
um listening to what everyone is saying
we've got some obviously some different
perspectives and I would propose that we
try to split the difference here as best
we can and I would offer that we do a
1.5 percent increase
um year over year
would that be for both years or just for
22 to 24 23 to 24. are you talking about
both years that would be
both years since I believe the previous
thought process was 2.5 percent
uh year over year for both years
okay so the motion uh is to recommend a
1.5 percent increase
from the 2023 number we agreed upon for
2024 and then another 1.5 percent
increase on that for 2025. is there a
second
oh thank you
okay uh clarification yep clarification
um apply it against what the percent is
going to be applied against
the against 308.5
which is No it should be the higher
number shouldn't it and then you
go right help us out so right so what
we'll do is we'll take the 308.5 being
the estimate of the net revenue for 23
We'll add back the municipal Revenue
transfer We'll add back the school
building Aid will then gross it up by
the percent in this case or in this
option the one and a half percent will
take out the new school building Aid
we'll take out the new Municipal
transfer to give you a net number and
we'll repeat that same procedure
um for 25 and just for clarification the
reason for doing that is
the municipal Revenue transfer and the
school building Aid is revenue that was
collected it just gets put in a place
that's restricted
um and does not flow into the general
fund so you need a general fund number
for your Revenue estimating purposes but
the revenue is still collected so we
want to make sure we account for that
when we do grow the revenue so this is
why we need them to do their numbers and
why we're talking about a percentage
right now so that makes perfect sense
I'd like to add Point 1.5 for 24 and 2.5
for 25 I think both of these numbers are
probably too low by the way but on
there we're likely to be coming out of
whatever we're stuck with by 25.
and the track record of males and rooms
certainly just
is more than that by a lot
other comments before we take a vote on
the current motion yes representative so
just so to be sure everyone follows it
right 1.5 up in 24 augmented by a
further 1.5 and 25.
do we have a motion or yes yep that was
a motion and it was seconded uh it was
made by representative janigan and
seconded by representative soti on
using our Base number that we already
agreed upon and then adding a 1.5
percent adding another 1.5 percent the
next year and letting them do their
magic with spreadsheets
so we get to the right net transfer to
the end
of it yes it got confused I thought they
said they'd do several scenarios and so
I thought we could give them like three
different percents they'd get them all
done and then afterwards we'll we know
what we were working with
but I may have misunderstood oh well but
it's going to take them a little time to
come back and do that so I don't know
how long you want to wait for them to do
that that's the only thing I thought it
was quick for them to do 1.52 years in a
row
so if we said 1.5 if we agreed to this
is that something you could tell us the
numbers right now or do we need to take
a break and come back it'll take a few
minutes okay so Madam chair
representative fellows I I don't even
know where we are so I understand
[Music]
um
an additional The Proposal which I not
really don't agree with I think it's too
low but the proposal for for
2024 is to add 1.5 percent and for 25
add 1.2 percent the thing that I'm lost
on is
are we giving them a number
423 or we already gave them the number
for 2023 we voted on that part okay and
that gives them a good base to then
figure that 0.5 yes okay yes so yeah so
that's what we already did
um how about this why don't we take a 10
minute stretch break
uh after we let's take a vote on this
because we have a motion before us and
then see where that lands and then like
take a 10 minute stretch break come back
um and see where we are and we still
have to deal with the real estate
transfer taxes
before we can take a lunch break so I
put just take a 10 minute stretch break
okay but we have a motion before us
the motion that was made was to
take use because we've heard multiple
things we had one recommendation of a
2.5 percent increase in the spirit of
compromise a 1.5 percent increase was
put forth
representative horse thank you madam
chair so I like rep alme's idea about
2.5 and 25 with a slight adjustment I'm
not sure who mentioned it down here one
of my esteemed colleagues mentioned 1.5
also in 2025.
uh just to help this committee out I'd
say you know let's go one five in 2024
and split the difference at 2.0 and 2025
just as a thought thank you
representative would you like to amend
um
I will amend my motion to be a 1.5
percent increase from 2023 to 2024 and a
2.0 increase from 20 from that number in
right so 1.5 2024 and then 2.0 2025. do
we have a second for the amended motion
well you made the suggestion would you
like to second that okay seconded by
representative orrs okay
let's just take a vote on that to see so
it's 1.5 increase and then a two percent
increase all those in favor raise your
hands
eight nine
ten eleven so that's eleven
and all those opposed
one
two three four five eleven to five does
take them out to seven against we just
need to count again yeah okay all those
who are opposed raise your hand because
I'm seriously yeah one two three four
so I don't I don't know how I'm missing
hands here so did everyone vote let's go
back to a house session all those who
were present what
yourself I did
okay
all those in favor raise your hand
no Mr would fight where's the clerk
please count
today
okay so so one of the challenges we have
folks changing their mind so that's
interesting so then all those opposed
okay so let's take a little break right
now stretch out a little bit I know you
guys been working really really hard and
we'll come back at uh 12 35 and go back
to this and try to do
I thought
did you give up on the lunch break
one more article that you want
foreign
she hasn't mentioned is that
the Communications tech to real estate
well yes but she wants where's the lunch
break
after we do real estate transfers and
there's the only thing that's left is
Communications that
we skip lunch that's fine with me I'll
thank you
Robin
okay
yeah
room chair after we get the numbers from
Chris and the Dr Ray could we chew on
yes just to revisit where we are today
so once we get rooms and meals done
and we get Highway and real estate
transfer text on we will then take a
solid one-hour lunch break
poor crochet will not take a lunch break
because he's going to be putting all
these numbers in a spreadsheet and then
we will come back and review them to
make sure they're accurate and then vote
on
hopefully he gets a snack or I'll go
order lunch right now and we'll get it
to happen Okay so we are still on rooms
and meals we've taken a number of
different votes and we're still a little
bit apart I'd love to see us a little
bit more together on that representative
janigan do you have any thoughts
I do thank you madam chair
after
talking to people some more and trying
to come to a a further consensus the the
last vote um
favoring our our 1.5 and 2.0 but in an
effort to get a little more consensus I
would like to make a motion that year
over year from 2023 to 2024 we we stay
with that same 1.5 percent increase but
from 24 to 25 we raise that to 2.5 so it
would be 1.5 percent and then 2.5
percent and um
hopefully we get further consensus is
there a second
oh representative Southwest second set
okay we've had a lot of discussions so
why don't we just take a vote to see if
that helps us move the needle to a
little bit better consensus unless did
you have a comment representative moment
okay okay great all those in favor of
janigan's motion of 1.5 percent increase
in 2024 2.5 percent increase in 2025
one two three four five six
and ten eleven eleven six excellent so
we both counted 16 all those opposed
raise your hand
one
did we lose someone
oh we lost someone okay
okay so that's it feels like a better
consensus to me thank you so much
everyone I really appreciate it it is
tough on these things because we all
represent different parts of the state
with a little bit different perspective
on things could you just give us the
numbers not just the percent but the
numbers for those teams that's why yeah
we have to do this one differently I
apologize but now he can plug in numbers
along with the commissioner and we'll
get the the final numbers and then we'll
have all that to look back at and vote
on later okay so now we will go to
the tough one
real estate transfer taxes maybe it's
tough maybe it's not maybe we'll be all
on the same wavelength on that
representative spilsbury
thank you madam chair
um
I'm proposing I'd like to make a motion
fat for 2023
we take the midpoint of the agency's
for
for FY 24
and
a slight further reduction to 211.
and when I
will speak to that when you give me the
opportunity absolutely so we have a
okay representative Platt seconds that
and yes representative spilsbury if you
could explain how you got to those
numbers
so I believe that the real estate
transfer tax is perhaps the most
volatile of the major taxes that we're
reviewing
um
and uh to the extent that we see uh
potential contraction in the business uh
Arena we're likely to see even more so
in the real estate Arena
the real estate transfer tax is
basically driven by two variables volume
and price
and those don't always act in sync what
we saw for example when the pandemic set
in
is that volume dried up
then prices started to include to
increase and the revenues took off in a
way that we didn't anticipate in late 20
and into 21 because of the price
appreciation
that Drew a lot of property into the
market and volume increased and really
propelled the the revenue and then the
prices got to a point in combination
with the recent interest rate hikes
where volume is Contracting
so I think we are moving into a period
where the prices are going to decline
again there's already
momentum in that direction in the last
several months I believe we're now
by the case Shiller index we have seen a
decline in each of the last six months
we tend to watch the residential real
estate market more accessible to most of
us in terms of what we see in the news
but if you watch the commercial real
estate markets
it's even I think more vulnerable
and I could I could relate specifics but
Pemco for example which is owned by
Alliance Bank in Germany
bought a major portfolio of commercial
Towers primarily in San Francisco and
New York primco's the largest Bond
portfolio in the United States and they
just defaulted
on 1.8 billion dollars in commercial
loans so I don't I'm not
forecasting a crash
but I think that when you see a downturn
in the real estate market it's going to
be magnified particularly when volume
and price are down simultaneously and
that's going to be the case I think for
a good portion of 24 and likely into 25.
I would just say one other thing in the
information that we've just gotten
showing a
20 30-year track record
of our revenues
it's striking that when contractions
have occurred
in around 2001 and 2002
the suddenness and steepness of the drop
in our real estate transfer revenues has
been as much as say 26 percent
so I think we need to be particularly
conservative of all of the revenue
streams we have this is the one that I'm
I would add that the feds are not done
increasing interest rates which does
translating the mortgage rates
eventually and the the higher the
mortgage rate the less the people will
want to Dicker down the price
essentially to be able to afford it or
not buy so both volume and uh and uh
average uh sale price probably will go
down and so I I do think we're facing a
recession it's going to affect here and
the FEDS with the inflation the feds are
going to jack up interest rates causing
representative DeSimone
thank you madam chair
on that line of thinking
um being a tax collector I've seen over
the last 25 years many things happened
one of which is when we go into a
recession
um first municipalities are required
within a five-year period of time to
re-evaluate the assessed values of their
properties so in a situation where
um we're in a recession if
as the dra does an equalization ratio
adjustment and and they check all of
that on an annual basis
um
a municipality can do a reval
in any particular year as long as it's
they meet the criteria of the five-year
period
and so what happens then as as was said
although the assessed values are not
equal to
the sales values they're pretty close
and if your assessed value comes from
six hundred thousand down to four
hundred thousand you're going to see a
big change in the sales price therefore
there's going to be a major decrease in
the transfer tax that's collected so I
think we have to be very conservative
with this figure
especially for 2025. representative
Southworth
uh thank you
um I agree with the 2023 uh proposal I
had 222 for both 24 and 25. I know
that's too many 20s in a sentence
um but 222 for 24 222 for 25 which is
basically the median I do think there
are factors that are going to hurt the
housing market but I also think there
still is um some pressure on prices
again in different parts of the state
um I agree I think this is the most uh
volatile area probably
but it's just hard to tell
um when some of the things are going to
hit whether they're going to hit in 24
representative I'm sorry Darby thank you
um
not disputing you know the the wise
words that were just spoken but I would
say that
um there as we all know that there's a
housing crisis in New Hampshire and some
municipalities Nashua where I'm from are
responding to that we have almost 2 000
units or well 1500 units that are
planned or underway
um and so those units are going to go up
for sale so it's not it's not a static
Market I guess is my perspective and
that's why you know I
um appreciate the the suggestions from
representative Southworth
may I just ask because I don't know
what's happening in the Nashua is that
are there more Apartments being created
in Nashville now are they actually
single-family homes where is the device
um there's there's both
um there's a lot of single family homes
going up
um there's a lot of uh condos going up
um you know it's dense housing most of
the housing that's going up is is dense
but
um
um the units as I understand them are
primarily individual sale units
other comments Representatives
um I I'm actually pretty good with the
figures for 23 and 24 but I I think that
you know this is going to turn around at
some point here so I would I would more
like to see 25 at the at the 215 level
which you know
because it's not going to go down and
down and down Forever at some point it's
going to turn around
all the comments representative sodi yes
the question does anybody else know any
other districts that are like building
I see Manchester with all sorts of
additions Big Time Dover is building a
lot of time yeah okay great that's what
we need right that's what we're looking
for excellent I just didn't know if they
were more on the apartments or more like
single-family homes or condos that you
would see that transfer tax
representative gagne
in Manchester I speak for Manchester it
would be multiple
apartment apartment dwellings across the
street on Elmo street across the street
from Market Basket there's a big couple
of hundred unit being built there
they're tearing apart on Pearl Street
one uh parking lot and putting up multi
apartment buildings there there's all
kinds of
major
Millions upon millions of dollars worth
of construction people Street's another
one that I just read about and they took
the other concern that the Torah
building down with all the proper
permits but it's gone well keep in mind
though for the purposes of this tax
revenue we're looking at sales of of the
entity so just building more units is
awesome thank you but it doesn't turn
into tax revenue unless that building
older sells yes representative thank you
that's what I was just going to say in
in these buildings that are being built
now it seems to me that those sales
would be in 2023 and maybe in 2024 but
again we have 2025 to look at when we're
going to be really entrenched in
some serious issues so I think we need
okay seeing no other comments we have a
motion on the floor
um did you want to amend that
yes Madam chairman
um
I would be pleased
on the basis that it's likely to develop
okay let me just let's just repeat
though the numbers so we're all clear
FY 2023 would be 228.5 correct 2024
would be
215 215 and then keeping it at 215 for
2025. yes okay I agree to amend it if my
secondary
my second your secretary agrees to amend
it
one all those in favor of the new
numbers raise your hand
Oh yay that is almost awesome but good
okay one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten eleven twelve thirteen
fourteen fifteen okay so we have 15 yes
four
what is support which support
we got another three apologize you're
right
yes sorry
so 15 to 3 is where we're at for Real
Estate transfer Texas so that's a pretty
decent majority thank you
okay no we have highway so flip your
pages over
now we have some folks here who have
experience dealing with highways anybody
okay so do we want to break these out
into three different things so you'd be
talking about column a yes okay
representative
okay my motion is to go with the agency
estimate 124 3 125 125 6. for 23 24 and
25. okay is there a second second
in seconds
okay let's hear your thoughts
can anybody here understand why
on
they think that it's going up in 23 when
at least the Turnpike tolls that I've
been following a long time that I gave
people copies of too late last night to
look at probably show on
a lot of
of red ink for 23 over 22.
my responsibility because the weather
was terrible yeah but this isn't the
this isn't the Turnpike tolls this is
the gas tax I know I know but that on
presumably the same thing it would be
happening off the turnpikes
we don't get the numbers though I
understand they have the numbers and we
should have tried to get them
inside at least at one point they
produced numbers from dot or traffic
representative
um to
potentially answer representative Ami's
question I I don't know the exact answer
but I do know that I read recently that
we
've got 7 000 new residents in New
Hampshire in the last three years
that's automatically going to mean them
filling up a large portion of them
driving traditional gasoline vehicles
will be filling up and there seems to be
a continuing Trend right now anyhow for
people coming from
some of the other states especially
Massachusetts the millionaires tax is
potentially estimated to bring more
people from Mass up here as well so
um
because you're right in general if you
if if it was static and populations were
static slowly people are buying
electronic vehicles that number would go
down but I think it's the increasing
other comments
questions thoughts representative Darby
I'm sorry um I'll just say that
um the um with the increase in
population this is this is only a 0.5
percent increase you know year to year
that's what it looks like to me so it's
and that's that's going to be under the
rate of inflation and
um and this you know this is based on
the gas tax is fixed cents per gallon
yeah this is the gas tax cents per
gallon and so it it goes up only because
the number of gallons are go up which
means more mileage and that's the
additional population and maybe more
people taking vacations up here
representative fellows did you have a
comment no okay all right so we have a
motion before us to basically accept the
agency estimates for 23 24 and 25. all
of those in favor accepting those please
one two three four five six
seven eleven twelve thirteen fourteen oh
everyone so we're good 18 to zero anyone
opposed
okay great
consensus on that one
okay Chris defer did we miss anything
oh we still have to do the other columns
yeah very small amounts but we'll do
okay and I'll take them one by one
miscellaneous of voting move to again
accept the agency estimate which is
0.2.2 and 0.2
second
all those in favor of accepting that
and you want to post
okay 18-0 on that
representative Platt my third motion is
a motor vehicle fees is keep with the
agency estimate surprise surprise which
is 133.2
uh the 133 6 and 133.5
is there a second
representative janigan's Second Step any
discussion
I don't understand why they are
essentially flat on Motor Vehicle fees
when I think we're still trying to
digest the change from a four-year to a
five-year
or was it a five-year to a four year I
forget four to four to five four to five
yeah
maybe maybe that year isn't in those
four
[Music]
there's anything else representative on
me on that no okay all right yes oh
sorry representative gagne I think
there's someone
a three-term and transportation I think
the motor vehicle fees might be because
they're
fewer new cars being purchased at this
time and people are keeping their uh
used cars a lot longer and the motor
vehicle fees are less the older the car
becomes
excellent thank you
okay all those in favor accepting the
all of those opposed okay it looks like
unanimous at 18-0
are we done on well done for now you
cannot leave please
you guys have done an amazing amazing
job thank you so much Chris how much
time do you need
before you want to reconvene
foreign
Okay so
what's that two can we let's shoot for
215 if that's okay just because people
have long drives home
um okay let's be back here 2 15 and um
hopefully
um we'll have what we need and we can
okay
Democrats
especially the ones staying through uh
please meet in the cafeteria
things
yeah I'm not sure that Linda well Linda
is
yeah I don't know who our subject's
going to be next week we're down one
wow Chris got it done thank you thank
okay so before you you have uh hopefully
everything that we have talked about and
voted on together in a consensus
fashion
and now is our chance to Eagle Eye it
and if we see any kind of mistake Now's
so take your time go through it compare
the meals and rooms are gross before the
Madam chair
is it time to ask a question uh yeah I
hold on everyone good looking at this do
we need more time
good I'm just asking a general question
okay go ahead
just wanted to make sure
um for the totals
2024 to 20 uh 25.
um
the revenue only goes up one million is
that because of the loss and interest in
dividends that knocks out the other
increases
it's the only big loss I see from 24 to
25 is interest in dividends
because most other things go up a little
they just don't do that
um if I look at
age
line 19.
goes up one million to line 25.
most other things on line 19 to line 25
go up slightly except for interest and
dividends drops quite a bit
so is that drop and interest in
dividends sort of canceling out all the
other ones that are going up slightly
that may be part of it representative
yeah because that's a big draw
and that would account for
um
the end result right I just wanted to
so that's something that's already built
in so it really you know is is a
the municipal transfer part of that too
if you're comparing
22 to r25 so the municipal transfer
isn't in the revenues it's subtracted
from the meals and rooms
so that's what Lindsay and I worked on
um when we took that short break earlier
but was it subtracted in 22
. so yep
okay so that's not so so we're trying to
get you Apples to Apples comparisons
with the meals and rooms Revenue so we
we netted out the municipal transfer in
23 24 and 25 so we had to do
calculations to get that one too
so in 20
no I understand that I'm comparing 22 2
yes 25 yes so 22 the municipal transfer
has been taken out it's accounted for in
the act for
uh representative Southworth
just quickly running through the lines
you're right about interest and
dividends being the primary driver who's
23 million they're about four others but
hey tobacco yeah and uh yeah I have them
circled and other and you've got your
answer it does yeah and that's just cash
out for one small increases that we did
in others yeah real estate too yeah
right yes that's I have those circles
yep
okay
do you want to just walk us through this
a little bit and point out some things
for us we make sure we're looking at
starting on page four is the start of
your general fund education trust fund
revenues
your business taxes on line 13 for
fiscal year 23 the committee tentatively
agreed to a number of
1.235 billion
then Nightline 19 was 1.2 billion
and line 25 is 1.215 billion so that was
done earlier today
yep everyone agree with that those are
the numbers we agreed to okay great go
to column B we'll do the meals and rooms
you came up with a base number in fiscal
year 23 and line 13 at 308.5
from that and with the desire to grow
the revenue by 1.5 percent and 24 and
2.5 percent in 25. so what we had to do
was take the 308.5 which is a net
revenue and gross it back up to a number
prior to the municipal Revenue Municipal
transfer happening so that brought you
to uh a gross revenue of 436.5 million
from that we grew up by the 1.5 and then
again by 2.5
and that results in row 19 of 309.5
million in row 25 of 318.9 million
because from that we removed the
municipal transfer
mathematically is it the same thing if
you just grow the net by 1.15 wouldn't
come out the same
so the transfer to the municipal Revenue
it it's close because the revenue is
close but the transfer is based on the
prior year revenues and so and you have
to make some adjustments to that with
what gets transferred in education trust
fund some administrative expense so when
that 30 is calculated it's on a
tobacco
this was you did this the I think Monday
but I could be off on that row 13 was
219.9
row 19 was 214 4.
and I'll just keep going through it
unless somebody stops you guys see
something that looks different from your
notes let's just stop and check it out
column D liquor transfer
row 13 was 130 million dollars row 19
interest in dividend which you worked on
today
roll 13 was 135
insurance tax under column F row 13 was
row 13 is 28 9 19 was 28.9 and row 25
real estate transfer tax on column H row
13 was 228.5
column I is the court fees you did this
the other day
um row 13 was 13 8 19 row 19 is 13 9 and
row 9 25 is 14 1. excuse me
Securities Revenue
was 45
8 and 46 6.
beer tax was 13-2
column L which is the other Revenue
we had 97 and 23 99 and 25 and 94.6 in
25.
Lottery Revenue was 170.8
tobacco settlement
was 42
under page six let's start with column o
which is the utility property tax
row 13 was 42.8
Statewide property tax was 263.1 and
363.1 and 24 and 25.
Medicaid recoveries was 2.6
2 and 2.1
when you go to column r that gives you a
total of
3.115.1 for 23.
for row nine it's 3.134
and for row 25 it's three one three five
the last two columns after that is just
to show you
um up to that point it's current law
and if people were wanting to see what
the governor's revenues and His official
estimates were it doesn't include CST
Revenue in 24 and 25 so that just makes
an adjustment the last two columns if
there's some questions on comparability
those are your Highway funds that you
in in all instances you took the
agency's recommendation so in 23 row 10
you have 124.3 0.2 and 133.2 for a total
row 15 you took 125.
133.6 for 258.8 which matches the
governor but it's just in a slightly
different bucket
so those about two hundred thousand
dollars that was added to the gas road
toll and taken out of the motor vehicle
fee but the total number is the same
and it's the same type of thing for the
fiscal year 25 uh row 20 you had 125 6
200 000 and then 133.5 for a total of
259.3
so that's your Highway
uh unrestricted revenues you go to page
10 you have your fishing game on
restricted revenues
which you did the other day
row 11 you had 9.8 and 4 million for a
total of 13.8 million
using the agency's estimates as they
provided some more up-to-date figures
and then for six row 16 you had nine
eight and three point six for 13.4 and
the same numbers for 25.
which aligned basically with the
governor's numbers
and the agency's numbers and so that's
and correct me Chris if I have this
wrong but uh my quick calculations show
that
when we consider the governor's revenues
versus
the likely house Ways and Means
estimates
that
in the first year 23
were 42 million dollars
um
higher
that I'm a governor
or is it lower lower I'm sorry lower
yeah lower
and then in the following year
and um
I'm looking at the
column that includes the removal of
communications tax
um
where 28 million lower
26 do I do that wrong
28.
um and then in the 25 were almost
exactly the same 3 million less and
again that's after
the communications tax is is that do I
have that right
you do if you were comparing to what the
governor's proposing yeah
um when the Surplus statement is put
together by our office we would use
current law so we would add back the 28
um 0.9 related to the communication
services for the governor right and then
we'd have an adjustment on schedule two
to take it back out
so what I I want to uh I wanted that to
be on the table that to be clear on that
that sort of bottom line point and then
um
I will say that I expect to vote for
these Ways and Means numbers
um but with with reluctance I've
expressed myself before on the
uncertainty of our effort here and I'm
in particular on the business taxes and
the rooms and meals taxes I I think
we're coming in uh too low that's my my
opinion as just an opinion and
that if if we did better on on that
account we'd
but as I say I will I will vote for this
uh be in the interest of moving this on
in the budget process and also with the
understanding that with new information
if it's significant that we will have
the opportunity to express ourselves on
that
representative what
countering that any governor democrat or
republican tends to be optimistic in
their a revenue forecast I think they
want to paint a Rosy picture how things
are going and so I we're a little less
than the governor it doesn't bother me
yeah I was calculating out how far off
we are from the midpoint of each agency
or that all the agencies together
which is mostly the dra
um and we're down just 1.3 percent from
the midpoint for
um
and 1.1 percent in 25.
so we're we're pretty damn close it is
um painful
for the places that the finance
committee would have to find other money
for or or get rid of which is
76 million
representative self-worth
uh thank you basically uh ditto what
representative Ames said I still think
those two areas may be higher but I'll
like dra our crystal ball is very cloudy
today so we just don't know but thank
you all for your hard work on this
um representative orrs
thank you madam chair yeah I
like what I hear from representative
Ames if the numbers were to adjust
sharply before things are done I hope we
could go back and revisit some of them
but I don't know if that being a rookie
I don't know if that's possible thank
you
we can always make our case
what the finance listens to us they are
an independent body but we we are the
ones who are the revenue experts and
they have not asked me any details about
what we're doing they are waiting for
our advice on that so I hope they will
continue to ask Our advice on that
thank you
um I don't remember doing it but I
believe that
towards the end of March if we felt we
had enough information that we hadn't
had before
from insurance or somebody
that we could go back to finance and
they would probably be very happy if it
that they I'm sure they'll have a list
of things they would have liked to Chunk
in
I know know that you are all really
watching on a daily basis what's
happening with our revenues and we'll
continue to do so and that is great
because if we start to see some really
strange things we should be talking
about it and we should be alerting
people
up or down whichever way they go but we
will have more numbers every month and
we will talk about them
absolutely so we have a total total
numbers before us and it would be
appropriate to have a motion to accept
those numbers for the three years
is anybody interested in uh
representative janigan
thank you madam chair
I make a motion to accept
these Revenue estimates as we have
before us in the document entitled March
second
thank you very much well I thank you
very much we can continue discussing
this but we have a motion before us to
accept the revenue estimates that we
have all put together which are totaled
on Page Six
all those in favor please raise your
hand
all those pose please raise your hand
s wonderful that is wonderful
I cannot thank you enough for your hard
work today we can continue to discuss
this uh now or we can call it and we can
go home and we can let Chris do his
magic so that we will have a resolution
on the floor for next Thursday March 9th
uh and uh if all goes as planned
representative and almu and I will stand
up there and present it and answer
questions and hopefully get everyone to
this is just for the chair the chair has
to be around after he puts in the green
sheets to make sure that the numbers are
we will all keep checking and rechecking
but yes absolutely anything else anyone
wants to share before we head out thank
you for a wonderful substitutes you guys
were awesome thank you so much for being
here
yes
and I just want to give you a heads up
uh next Tuesday we have several work
sessions and one bill hearing the bill
hearing is a second committee bill and I
think representative ulery is an expert
on that so we'll be looking forward to
hearing from him on that uh and then on
Wednesday we have exec sessions and I
just listed every build that we've
already had a hearing on I am going to
move the start time to 115. hope that's
okay with everyone we will see what we
can get done then it is not an absolute
deadline day but I wanted to start
working through that list because the
next week is absolute deadline so just
we'll get what done what we can get done
what we feel comfortable at that time
the way I read the calendar
final deadline for bills for all bills
to be
the 30th
oh I read as March 16th did I read that
wrong oh no that's right I think uh if
their first if they're one committee
bills yes right but the other ones we
have until the 30th along with the
budget yes so every bill that I listed
on the exact session notice for
Wednesday
is something we've already heard and is
all that's remaining for us to exec by
March 16th right then we will have
several second committee bills one I
just mentioned to you about the oplc
um but we also have a big marijuana bill
coming to us guys so I'm gonna have to
schedule that soon uh just be prepared
that could take a little time
on representative Ames said and I agree
with him that the formatting
the order of of of
the different parts of the bill and a
fair number of other things are uh wrong
in the bill that we're getting
oh and I don't know if that's one of the
things they're trying to do now is to
fix references and fix the order of the
bill it is rather difficult to read at
this point I have to be honest with you
I haven't even read the bill yet I spent
the whole day reading it oh good for you
so we will uh when we have some time
sitting on our couch this weekend we can
all read that bill we I would recommend
waiting until they give us a complete
bill is amended I hope that will be
but otherwise uh it's insane you keep
yes representative Morris thank you
madam chair I'd love to read your Cliff
Notes on that if you're willing to share
them then I don't have to read the whole
way I will remind members though when we
get a bill as a second committee we are
not here to open up the whole policy
question whether it's education
marijuana anything even with the oplc
that decision has already been made by
the house our Focus will be on the
revenue aspect and I'd like to try to
keep us as focused on that assumingly
possible so that we can give our
expertise on that representative Olney
there is a problem with this with the
marijuana bill
and that they're assuming there's going
to be I think what
representative Abbas thought it was
going to be when he sent it to his last
term
and as we had done calculating time
after time in this committee we were
looking at 30 to 50 million a year Max
and they're looking to get rid of the
pension fund problems
with that money and do a bunch of other
things
and then the other problem is none of
them seem to know anything about farmers
and farming
and I've been in touch with the Farm
Bureau but I haven't heard back from
them about on whether they think that
the funding mechanism in their
is capable of working
because they are trying to get 15
percent of the gross
from Farmers every time every month
and these farmers are going to have had
enormous Capital expenses
if if I could ask all of you to think
about and advise me because we're gonna
have to schedule this soonish uh maybe
not next week but the week after how
much time we should allocate and how
much space I've already gotten a number
of phone calls uh the people want my
support and so forth so I don't know if
we're going to get a lot of people here
who's going to be here should we move to
reps Hall I'd love to get your input on
that so we can schedule it properly
um
yes please um
I think part of that which we've had
trouble with on this committee before is
we have to make it crystal clear that
we're not talking about the underlying
bill because in the past the people that
are pro or whatever have all come and we
haven't been able to listen to them or
anything so I think somehow making that
clear also I assume the dra will be
available when we're talking about the
money
is it dra or is it liquor correction
exactly that someone will be yes yes uh
this analysis themselves before
they were part of our work product
before
representative abrami is very much part
of our work product also by the way uh
and liquor
as I think I pointed out last time
liquor but maybe it was someone else
liquor understands wine in bottles
uh plants grown grown even in a
greenhouse
on and
and
um
customers that come into a totally
separate out out uh
I think the retailers are going to just
have to get licenses this time which is
an improvement but
um
I wonder if it makes sense that I'll
reach out to our committee researcher to
see if she can get some other data from
other states and so forth okay that's
what we
done before and what we depended on all
the other states data and there is maybe
we could distribute representative
abrami's latest uh
report on a cannabis
he was he doesn't like cannabis but he
was very fair about this
okay absolutely
uh did you have anything you want to add
or okay great yes representative
um two things number one I don't know if
it's done but maybe it ought to be that
in the legislative calendar when this
comes up there should be in bold caps
please don't put more nicely than this
please don't come debating whether you
want marijuana legalized or not or
decriminalized or not we are only
talking about financial implications I
will consult with a house Clerk and how
we can delicately but firmly say that
and and yes I would ER one of the very
few rules I have for myself is it almost
always takes longer than you think and
it doesn't matter what it is so however
much time you might think we need maybe
add 50 percent
yeah and just so you know the chairman
of Commerce who is the one who has sent
this bill to us has requested that he
wants to be here at nine nine a.m for
whatever the hearing date is so just be
prepared I know we prefer 10 in this
room but he has asked for 9am so I will
try to accommodate him what's that
yeah well just the chairman of the
Commerce Committee has a lot of bills
and he's trying to get through those and
most of his stuff starts at 10. so he
needs to start here with us and then
continue on from there representative
rough guesstimate is the marijuana
Revenue was take Massachusetts and
divide by seven
that sounds very scientific the the
logic is uh no the logic is six million
people there one million people here
we're buying a mass so uh we would we
would retain the Massachusetts
uh the people buying it messages would
buy it here so so we if we're one one
seventh of the uh population of both
States
I'm sure we'll get more information on
this so uh that's that's going off a few
weeks so we we got this major hurdle
done
oh sorry representative Ames I I think
you'll pick this up anyway but as I
recall there's not a fiscal note on this
uh Bill and
and uh The Liquor Commission I think is
the responsibility now and so
I I would push for you may not get it
but for our fiscal note there should be
a fiscal note
I thought I read one and I thought it
said how much it would cost to build a
new store and uh the number of employees
and all that wasn't that uh
okay it wasn't on this one
okay so substitutes if you're interested
in this topic maybe you can come back
yes representative
thank you madam chair
um I haven't read the bill don't know
how it compares the last term but I
remember proceedings last term vividly I
think we're going to have a robust
extensive hearing but I try to confine
it to a single day I would however plan
another day for a robust committee
discussion before we try to exec
anything
representative horse thank you madam
chair so
I don't smoke anything I don't gamble
but if it increases New Hampshire's
coffers I'm all for taking the Caps off
gambling if we can out-compete the other
states and bring that money in here for
our education and our state
and as far as cannabis
there's a now defunct Getty Gas Station
near my house in Chichester
and I thought if we went and pooled our
resources and said Getty your cannabis
here we could be on the Forefront
thank you
on that note have a wonderful evening
and thank you oh yes representative
fellows could you just go over the dates
that you know that we're going to meet
or did you say something about next week
okay so uh off the top of my head I have
to think about this a little bit
um two yeah nothing on Monday not the
house I'm talking about just his
committee yeah so nothing on Monday okay
Tuesday starting at 10 we have a house a
bill hearing
nope that's not it the office of
Professional Licensing is coming to us
as a second committee and then we're
going to have three full committee work
sessions on bills that we talked a lot
about but so we just need to talk some
more about maybe get some more details
um so those will be listed in the
calendar and then on Wednesday will be
exec session in the afternoon
Thursday we have the Full House session
so we only meet in the afternoon on
Wednesday yes
okay okay and then then after that I
haven't got my head around it yet I'll
meet with the vice chair and we'll try
to see what we have left for bills we
have to schedule and try to get them in
the next week I just checked with the
chairman of the criminal justice
committee who we share this room with
he's apparently done his work so we have
pretty good access here so leave
yourself available that week of the 13th
I think so we can get as much done as
possible keep in mind it's it's a lot of
hard work in the house until April 6th
through April 6. then it gets a little
easier
representative
gets a little bit easier in the week
between when we have to hand them the
bills and the and the meetings on the
floor
but I think everything you said we're
already committed to is in the calendar
already
sucks
only thing is I had to change the exact
session time from 10 a.m to 1 15 and I
apologize about that
yes this is just procedural when
we're second committee can we retain a
bill when we're the second committee
okay
yeah we could all who have all the same
same thing
okay